can the heat burn the calamity away as
it turns out no no it cannot but it can
draw your attention to the searing site
of the subscribe button for the new
ultra view the pressing of which will
deliver regular Jojo content uploaded
straight into your YouTube feed hello
and welcome to the new order video
source for everything anime and manga
and today we are flipping the whole
concept of Jojo Monday because we have a
new chapter of Jojo Leon to review and
to put it quite simply I refuse to wait
until Monday to talk about it because
there is a lot of crazy crap happening
here in endless calamity part 3 and this
is kind of insane because everything I
thought I could take is mostly factual
from the last chapter as once again
being thrown completely up into the air
and with this I'm primarily talking
about Toru and the head doctor what is a
stand and what isn't and to start where
we left off going back to my thoughts on
chapter 96 I was probably about 99%
certain that Tohru was the stand user
and that the entire concept of the head
doctor was just his stand at work
however after chapter 97 I am
significantly less sure about that
evaluation and there's a fair few ideas
swimming around in my head thing but
initially just to address this though
the very first shot of the head doctor
that we see in this chapter is pure
nightmare fuel it immediately evokes
this Blair Witch vibe which I guess
spoilers for a film from 20 years ago
seeing one of the characters standing in
a corner like this was easily the most
and potentially only truly terrifying
moment of that very slow burn film but
artistically this panel is so well done
and it's through an incredible set of
features there's just something really
nice about our Kees choice to have an
almost completely blank set of walls in
this room I mean there is a clock but
that's fine you do need something I
guess but the effect of these white
walls more or less creates negative
space there and it allows this panel to
truly zero in on the head doctor and
present this moment from the perspective
of the reporter with his laser-like
focus on his subject
there's nothing superfluous in the space
so the head doctors figure is striking
and immediate and I guarantee you if
this room was filled with more stuff
like I don't know medical awareness
posters and such then this panel would
not have anywhere near the same effect
as it does so this is very much a
masterclass of simplicity and focus and
it's also a really cool way to introduce
us to this new speaking doctor entity
because at first our key obviously
intends for us to believe that this is
another incarnation of the stand that
has been pursuing the rest of our cast
so it creates some genuine surprise when
the head doctor turns around and offers
his business card like any up Stan
ding Japanese businessman it was a great
subversion of expectations that has now
humanized and characterized the head
doctor and has thus led me to
questioning I don't know everything the
only thing I can really say with any
certainty now is that it is clear that
Toru and the head doctor have a
connection at play here and quite
possibly a connection through stand work
and I know that might sound too obvious
and pointless to say but in the end I
feel like that really is what we know
despite the fact that we've been
exploring the stand for far more
chapters than I recall off the top of my
head right now and yet we still know so
little about it look it's fascinating so
I might say frustratingly fascinating
I'm not one of them er I love this
mystery because it's just so damn
compelling to read about and speculate
on every chapter of Jojo Leone featuring
the head doctor has fired up my
imagination like any good mystery should
and in fact I think this micro mystery
is probably my favorite of all pod 8 as
it currently stands but start going back
to chapter 96 the accepted theory there
was that the head doctor is Taurus
turned and despite all the
characterization that he was given in
this chapter that could still very much
be true it would just be a more complex
version of a long-distance automatic
stand like job in theorizes in this
chapter the thing about those stands
though is that they generally aren't too
complex in nature and they tend to have
a very singular objective and I'm not
quite sure if I see one being capable of
human interaction on such a subtle level
of which there was a lot of examples in
this chapter like that whole discussion
about opening jars potatoes and smelling
things but this leaves us with the idea
that the head doctor is indeed an actual
entity and judging from how this
reporter met his unfortunate fate it
would imply that he is also the one who
generates the calamity stand but even if
we accept that then we still need to
figure out how Toru fits into everything
because judging by the end of this
chapter he does have some sort of direct
link to the head doctors actions and one
thought that came to mind is that
perhaps all of this madness is a bit too
much to be enveloped in a single stand
and maybe what we're dealing with here
is a combination of two stands one from
the head doctor and one from Tohru so
for example let's say that the head
doctor has the calamity stand and that
seems to inflict its abilities based on
the condition of pursuit which was
directly referenced by the doctor during
this chapter
cool that's fine but then what if Tohru
has a stand that allows him to replicate
the image of the head doctor somehow as
well as the conditions of said stand
that would be a pretty ultimate
combination and potentially a much more
satisfying explanation than this all
being the work of a single stand under
the
tooru but i guess things just don't
quite add up yet if the head doctor is a
stand himself then he doesn't really fit
into the established typings i just
don't think it can be fully cognitively
functional and have a long-range
automatic use although who knows maybe
it's just plain overpowered but
accepting the head doctor is real then
once again Toru still has to be involved
somehow so why not have a dastardly
stand combination happening and this
leads us to the whole thing about Toru
listening to music during this chapter
two songs in particular being crazy
trained by Ozzy Osbourne and the wonder
of you by certain Elvis Presley and very
very notably the wonder of you was the
name of the story arc that preceded
endless calamity so that may very well
even be the name of tourists and and
what's interesting is that after the
beginning of the ova song it looks like
Tohru receives visions of yo hos current
situation which is writhing around in
agony as it has been for the last few
months so if anything maybe tourists and
is even more simple than I initially
posited and it just allows him to form a
link with people through choosing a song
to represent them which does make sense
in the case of yo ho because the wonder
of you you know fit sumito his general
feelings towards her so in that case
maybe crazy train was the song that he
chose to form a link to job in actually
probably meets ABBA because you get a
close-up of her eyes just before cutting
to Tohru outside and actually I think it
does have to be meet super wouldn't it
because job and still can't see the head
doctor although actually if they're two
separate stands that doesn't even matter
at all doesn't even come into it so
that's interesting maybe Tohru can do
far more than just simply watching
people and through his song link maybe
he is able to protect the image of the
head doctor directly into people or
around people I don't know and I guess
that also does become a bit difficult to
think about logically because there are
so many people being affected by the
head doctor at once
and surely Tohru can only listen to a
single song at a time alright my heads
getting model to you so who knows maybe
he's nothing but a glorified sentry
whose overall purpose is to keep an eye
on things and just provide information
and actually having gone into the whole
musical aspect I am convincing myself
more and more that the head doctor
calamity business isn't actually his
doing and is indeed the work of another
stand user and that would probably work
out quite nicely for the sake of
narrative flow as well because it gives
our characters to enemies to defeat
instead of just one and it looks like
our ki has made some clear group
divisions on the one hand we have Yasuo
and job in at the higashikata estate to
take on Toru and elsewhere we have Jo
schema mozuku poised to face off
against the head doctor and just a quick
note on that mama Zuko and josuke
obviously aren't in the same location
yet but it is interesting to think about
how that needs to happen because the
problem here is that mama Zuko can't
just follow the head doctor to find
Josie a Jew too you know deadly calamity
so in a weird situation he actually
needs to beat the head doctor to that
location which is a pretty awesome and
unique dynamic especially if the head
doctor realizes this and then some sort
of strange death race begins between the
two having brought him up though I do
need to touch on josuke because for the
first time in what feels to me like
forever he makes an appearance posing
like an absolute Jojo boss in a chair
and it's actually really good to see a
protagonist again because I'd almost
kind of forgotten that he was in the
story having switched to Jojo Lee a
monthly during all this madness so I am
glad that we are about to build up and
kick him into gear once more not a whole
lot else to say about Jo scale there are
just a super-hype panel but another
major character I need to talk about is
of course job in the first section of
this chapter focuses on he and meets
about picking up directly well last
month left off and man he just comes off
as so damn likable in this chapter which
is strange to say because two chapters
ago here I was certain that he was a
completely irredeemable antagonist but
then you have the revelation that Norris
K isn't actually dead in chapter 96 now
job and has a touching little piece of
dialogue thanking meets above for always
being by his side
and citing both her and Tsurugi as his
ultimate reason for being and it's all
just so touching I like the guy now I
like him a lot and in a twisted way I
still do kind of hope that he ends up
being the ultimate antagonist of Jojo
Leon because that would be an incredibly
conflicting and powerful finale
especially since he's still undoubtedly
a bit of a prick
given that he was ready and willing to
actually kill yo ho so it's not like
he's redeemed himself entirely but his
chosen path is becoming more I guess
sympathetic and that is what I want from
my antagonist and yes of course I am
making the assumption that job and does
live through this despite the hairspray
calamity just tearing him completely
apart because I just think it would be
the height of naivety to be convinced
the job in is dead as a result of that I
mean one of the things I actually kind
of dislike about Jojo are the incredible
amount of fake out deaths and so
whenever I see something like this it's
very very difficult to believe that this
is the end for a particular character
much less job and I will admit though he
might be mortally wounded and maybe it
will take some sort of you know fruit
related incident
to heal him on up again one that might
change him somehow but he's certainly
not dead yet there's just too much to
resolve about him to have this be his
end
plus if Norris gay isn't going to die
then there's no way that job in is once
again though I did really enjoy this
part of the chapter and in fact you know
what I pretty much enjoyed every aspect
of chapter 97 incredible stuff really
this whole endless calamity arc is just
such a super solid ride as I stated
before the sheer mystery at play here is
nothing short of captivating and it
makes me genuinely excited to read Jojo
Leone on a monthly basis which is
something that yes I was slightly afraid
of when making this transition I should
also say that at the end of this chapter
we got another time update till the
harvest which is now 2 hours and 11
minutes so it looks like we've now
travelled forward by just over an hour I
think from what I can recall I think
last time we had an update it was like 3
hours and 20 minutes or something along
those lines which was during the last
talk which is kind of crazy because at
that point we were doing the whole job
and throwing the phone in the toilet and
drowning out of her business so somehow
between then and the end of this chapter
apparently more than one whole hour has
passed which I'm not exactly sure where
happens because these events play out
fairly back-to-back particularly in
regards to the higashikata estate so
yeah I'm not quite sure how that really
works but it's what we've got and sure
why not it's always exciting to move
ever closer to the time of harvest and
they also want to go into our keys
message in this month's issue which was
very simply I'm hard at work drawing so
you don't have to worry please continue
to be careful everyone and I only bring
that up because manga production and
release has been affected elsewhere
specifically in Weekly Shonen Jump which
is currently undergoing a saw
publication schedule but it looks like
ultra jump as a monthly magazine is not
facing those same issues which is a
relief and as such I am greatly looking
forward to the continuation of this
brilliant talk next month what do you
guys think please do let me know in the
comments below and if you're keen for
someone Church or content and please do
go and check out some of my other videos
or even subscribe to the channel for
regular joe jawanda
delivered straight into your YouTube
feed but for now this has been the New
World review and I'll see you next time